it became a business where they were
bringing in millions of pounds of time
Mexican hash they were bringing them in
ships they were dropping off a hundred
thousand pounds of Seattle 30,000 pounds
of in Eugene off the coast hit the hit
where we are San Francisco all the way
down Santa Barbara and the ship's ago
well they would bring those loads in and
unload them for people or probably would
get twenty twenty-five thousand pounds
people would get four or five thousand I
was like the youngest guy getting a
thousand pounds of time and back then
that was the early 80s and late
seventies that was like a million to $5
on fronts handshakes no deposits no
anything
so you guys are young in 1970 a man
working as an electrician could have a
house three kids wife no debt have the
boat and have a property in the
mountains okay
that's gone there's none of that now you
got two people work and they can't have
half that okay they just took it out
from under us to me it's serving people
in the world is unconditional know
someone's opinion to me contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on we are on site
at the beautiful new West Summit we are
now going to be talking to Tim Blake I'd
say hey fantasy thank you so much for
coming on the show really appreciate it
it's a pleasure
Tim's backgrounds epic he's the founder
and producer of the Emerald cup which is
the world's largest outdoor organic
cannabis competition and he did that 16
years ago he also earned his real estate
license the age of a 19 he's been
founding a CEO of several production
companies and 1980s so many other things
on this list a founding member of the
California cannabis reform policy CC PR
there's a lot to dive into here Tim
let's start things off by asking you
about how did you get fascinated with
this at your youth and how they take us
through your journey
Oh cannabis well my family lived in the
Bay Area San Jose Sonny Belt I have six
brothers and sisters traditional
middle-class family you know Catholic
family and I was a hyperactive kid
extremely hyper and so in grammar school
I had well Hispanic kids had some
cannabis and I didn't get high the first
couple times but I think 7th grade sixth
grade seventh grade and the second or
third time I did and it was a really
amazing experience so I don't let me up
to the whole thing unfortunately he
moved away wasn't any more around it
kind of stopped we moved over to Santa
Cruz or Capitola right next to Santa
Cruz but my whole family when I was
going into high school and so now we
moved from San Jose in a liberal
suburban place into the belly of the
most liberal place in the country which
is Santa Cruz outside of San Francisco
so now we go over there to this place
right downtown there's a three-story
building I'm living in the old keg room
in the bar down below
I got a pool table the keg room
black lights go up everything's really
cool have a fun thing going on my
parents started smoking all this
cannabis with all the art community
which was part of capital at the time I
mean it was very very liberal and so I'm
basically stealing my dad's pot getting
pot from people you know coming through
the all the people local and I started
smoking a lot of cannabis and realizing
that for me being very hyperactive kid
it kept me off riddle and it kept me it
really balanced me very very much so at
the same time I realized some of the
largest dealers in town which were only
in their 20s were selling cannabis and I
got to know these guys and they started
selling me you know back then it was
kilos 2.2 bricks
you know 2.2 pounds and so I would get
2.2 pounds which was 32 ounces his two
pounds plus the point to which me a few
extra ounces and we'd smoke the extra
ounces and sell the turd at 32 and I'd
go to high school my hair was all way
down on my back it involved very quickly
I had at my mom and I had a dog named
hashish hash for short and all of a
sudden I was like in the middle of
capital and Santa Cruz is burgeoning
wild liberal scene of the early 70s and
it was an amazing place to be and so I
was doing that and at the same time I
started taking up trans love meditation
doing trans love meditation and cannabis
16 17 year old you know selling selling
but on the side every day of the week
and all of a sudden I had the
opportunity to kind of grow that
business these guys got big really quick
now you gotta remember when people
remember but the way it worked was it
was a very organic scene with a bunch of
hippies and Vietnam vets to stop
bringing people back cannabis from South
America or Vietnam or Asia that was very
organic well in the mid 70s that very
quickly formed into a huge business and
between 1975 76 77 all the way told they
changed the minimum mandatories and I
think 87 it became a business where they
were bringing in millions of pounds of
time Mexican hash they were bringing
them in ships they were dropping off
100,000 pounds of Seattle her thousand
pounds and in Eugene off the coast hit
hit where we are San Francisco all the
way down Santa Barbara and the ship's
ago well they would bring those loads in
there
four people are five would get 2025
thousand pounds people get four or five
thousand I was like the youngest guy
getting a thousand pounds at a time and
back then that was the early 80s in late
70s that was like a million to five
million dollars on fronts handshakes
no deaf posits no anything and it was
all well run you made your money it was
all clean there were no robberies it was
integrity based it was a it was a really
wonderful time actually I did I did
really well back then and I actually got
to the point where I was getting 5,000
pound loans which was from IH almost
unheard of they actually asked me how I
was doing it because I wasn't getting
the prices they were winning how I was
selling that and I was saying well at
all each thousand pounds they'd have
about 50 pounds of these a Plus+ bricks
and like the red ones are the golds and
so I would basically sell the 5000
pounds for cost
I just wholesale it and then just take
out those 250 pounds or those
eighth-graders and giving all my small
people so my small people had all the
best by the day area and so I make
couple extra bucks they'd be like the
hit of it the whole town and so I built
this whole business with that and that's
that's how come on through the early 80s
and then Wow
then a friend of mine showed up one day
one of the dealers and he said here I
got this stuff and it was the finest
cannabis that ever seen it was called
the chronic the grease the magic that's
what it became known as it wasn't known
at the time it was the furriest whitest
blood had ever seen strongest stuff but
probably better anything today and Big
Sur holy people put it together he said
you see this we're gonna all be growing
on those lights that you see in Safeway
within two years and I was like I had a
thousand pounds my backyard I'm like
you're out of your mind why are we gonna
grow under lights in a safe way he said
that's because they're gonna bust all
the loads the generals have already
talked about it they're gonna bust all
the loads in the next two years and
they're going to take it all out and
you're not gonna go to get cannabis any
more and I was like you're crazy I said
I'll buy all your pot but he wanted me
giving him a third of a third of every
crop for six crops and I couldn't get
one clone away and I was like you're out
of your mind to it I'm just a year and a
half later I went back and begged for
that clone
they busted 12 loads you can go back
historical and look at the news they
busted about 12 loads and
everybody realized it was all over the
DEA came in and he added something to it
at the time people in you know the poor
areas Oakland San Francisco everywhere
the people in the streets afro-americans
they were all getting a lot of but they
weren't doing crack okay within that two
year period they couldn't get any bud
but then get $10 grams of crack and they
just turned the whole thing upside down
just just turn it on us like overnight
that was predicted by the people in the
business they said that was gonna happen
I watched it happen I got damaged in 80
what year probably started in an 85 86 I
go back I look between 85 and 87 having
the started you got the the elements of
the bus started I think they probably
started coming in probably 86 we heard
about it 86 to 88 you know about 89 it
was totally dry everybody was making
runs to Arizona to try to bring back
something water back there it was nobody
could get anything that's why all this
indoor and outdoor blew up there was a
little bit of it going on of course but
not much because it wasn't any need for
it you were gonna bring in millions of
pounds a year of time Mexican it was a
forcing function of the indoor and
outdoor flourishing of California came
from the stopping of the importing from
Mexico mostly from Thailand from what
you know what's my land was growing more
most of this well yeah what happened was
is that people don't even remember this
but there were they were called the
sticks Thai sticks they were a famous
thing they wrapped Thai on a stick and
the reason why they did it was because
it wasn't that good so they could take a
whole bud and kind of bend it over and
wrap it on a stick and they'd sell it to
you so they first started coming in
there were these Thai stick pounds
okay well then they quickly realized and
Judy well if we don't put it on a stick
and we lay it in nice and light and do a
little light press on it you can get
these two packs of beautiful Thai buds
that just pull right off and they're
beautiful stunning almost rounded
beautiful bud
and so gives you ingenuity of American
wherewithal was we got taken out with
all those loads down south so people
started blowing up all the indoor and
outdoor because that went away but for
about ten years in the late 70s to that
period it became something where these
two packs came in
and that's what they were called they're
called two packs they were 2.2 is the
way the Mexican pounds were they were
just two packs they'd come in between
nine hundred and a thousand grams and
they became you get there you get the
Reds and almost the purples that
Golden's they were just unbelievable
phenomenal you know material and that's
what we lived off and it was really uh
it was really an amazing industry it was
a fun thing to be part of you were a
entrepreneur from the age of fifteen
fifteen just building up like a of a
massive network of people that were then
distributing cannabis across the Bay
Area it was it was it became pretty big
I probably had 25 30 guys working for me
and like you said as soon as that got
you had so many interesting nuances of
taking this best stuff and distributing
at cost to the distribution network
which then made it so they kept as like
the top dog so they that's why you were
so young and able to get a thousand
pounds at a time and that's crazy even
thinking about what a thousand pounds it
looks like that's like this whole room
filled with cannabis that kind of stuffs
and nuts and so then you know how were
you you know moving that in what like a
like in a in an actual like u-haul big
truck over to your you know and doing
this distribution process and then you
also taught about how the flip of like
when the when the it gets choked out
cannabis in the Bay Area people flip
over to using crack so they pushed it
into they put well cocaine I mean the
high-end people are doing cocaine and
they gave it to a lot of us all of a
sudden cocaine became you know we all I
mean a lot of us tried it for a very
short period realized what a toxic
nightmare that was but they didn't think
of much room you're looking at two packs
that you know pressed you know buds
about that long you could have you know
pack about that thick and about that
long and be a two pack so you could
stack those against the wall and you
could have you know hundred pounds
almost right there I mean this little
thing right here you can have
quite a bit it didn't take big big
trucks didn't take pants
no no and then I'd break it all down
everybody to get between 1500 pounds I
had ever you know I had 20 people
getting 50 200 pounds yeah they were
going on doing their thing and someone
else above you was getting twenty five
thousand well they were getting five
thousand above me and then 20 to 25
above that so what I was doing was I was
going to the people that were getting
like maybe 20,000 pounds but they
couldn't sell it all so I was
wholesaling that for them to help them
out and I wasn't making any money but I
was making those those high-graders so I
did I'd make like 5 bucks on those well
I get I would get 250 of those things
make 5 bucks apiece that's 125 grand
this is crazy so in the early 80s
Thailand was Manuel was making and
shipping hundreds of thousands of pounds
aliens now didn't it got million pounds
yeah it got grown other places
it became throughout Asia you know I
don't know if they're all growing at all
in Thailand but it became Americans
going over there and building really
massive businesses and the Americans
went there and built the actual they
cannabis for they put it all together
yeah it was basically just hippies or
stone or business kids and stuff that
just realized with the strains and what
they had what they could do what they
could build how easy it was there wasn't
any DEA so there's no really getting
busted with the shipping yet that DEA
didn't come in until about Drug
Enforcement Agency for people who don't
know that yeah that didn't come in until
the mid 80s when they brought in the
minimum mandatory zeis okay this is how
we're gonna get rid of that and they
said we're gonna bring the minimum
mandatories which meant if you had over
a thousand pounds it was like a minimum
you couldn't change it like a 10-year
prison sentence I had a guy that came
with the last load it was a the we were
partner but was about sixty seven
hundred pounds he brought it up he's
gonna see my friend and then I was gonna
see him and he went into the mountains
they followed him all the way out of the
Sierras and they didn't know where he
was going in the Santa Cruz Mountains
because they hadn't used phones and back
then
didn't have the phone technologies and
stuff and so they busted him before he
got there
now people put up 250,000 for that guy
and he did six months in county jail and
Milpitas okay a year later that was a
15-year prison sentence man minimum
mandatory fifteen prison and so then
they got people to roll on each other
they'd bust people want to be like okay
you're not going to just get two hundred
fifty thousand go to Milpitas for six
months now you're gonna go to jail for
twenty years are you gonna start rolling
on people in fact I were the the last
real load of international smuggled
stuff came in it was 23 pound twenty
three thousand pounds of hash I think it
was nineteen ninety right in there and I
wasn't part of it but I knew the family
that did the whole thing and they
brought it in they'd paid fifty thousand
dollars of peace to about twenty guys to
bring it offshore would all been paid
they stored it they had a giant party it
was like a celebration it was a who's
who of the cannabis world we sat down at
the party I was with this guy we had
skinny fatty some of these names we had
back then and I said you know what dude
you look around this is like a who's who
who's left of the industry and you guys
brought it in you know they were
celebrating stuff it's spent a bank on
that party and then three months later
they took them all out because they they
got they got the captain on it so they
hadn't sold anything and he went back to
all the the guys and said you got to
give it back to the two thousand apiece
because I need the million dollars to
defend myself and these knuckleheads
didn't do it they all their families and
their people and they thought okay this
is it we're gonna keep our money and
that's the way goes blah blah blah well
he looked at 15 20 years and they said
they'd give him five if he took them all
out so he took all 22 of them out and
the same he was right that's just facts
and so they all did four and a half
years dad for those guys holding on to
that 50 grand apiece they all went to
prison and he did four and a half rather
than 20 and I mean it was his deal he
should have done the time it's just the
story the way it went and so that was
really the end of it for me too
there was a couple little things I got
busted I got busted some of the only
time Mexican left
and the state why I didn't get busted
with it actually I was turned in by my
son of former salon whenever we talked
to like you know like Stevie Angela on
our show and stuff he always tech
teaches us about this place
several decade long strenuous process
that so many people had to go through
including these multi-year prison
sentences and just like what happens
when people flip from cannabis to harder
substances and do to those choke points
and stuff like that that happened along
this journey it's just such a
complicated evolutionary process that
happened with bringing cannabis back to
the light that indigenous people have
been using for thousands of years prior
to this and so it's kind of like a a big
in how it created this forcing function
to in California know if if it didn't
come in if the DEA and the 85 didn't
come in to do this choke on it
you called it Thai Mexican it could have
continued going though in that direction
where those economies could have
flourished and the California economy of
cannabis might have actually just
continued purchasing from over there
instead of doing it natively here so in
a sense it could be a gift in disguise
that was it was well you know in Chinese
mythology a crisis equals opportunity or
as the opposite so that crisis was our
opportunity so it you're right that did
make our markets blow up because we were
blowing up Asia and South America and so
it's an amazing thing the way that went
how is that that's such a weird as a
karmic the karmic thing that blew up in
the DEA space they thought they were
going to suppress us and what they did
was we just popped out went sideways
although or maybe there's something
above the DEA that said that you co
stopped that so that our native markets
can blow up so there's all different
kinds of theories that could potentially
spur from that yeah well if you want to
get up into the spiritual realm I think
currently it was more destined that it
was going to go this way
so that we would take back that and we
would have this legalization effort that
really spearheaded the whole world so I
think that's what happened because you
think that South America or
Asia wouldn't be able to spearhead a
legalization potentially something that
would I don't like what we went through
there was we had to go through this
karmic war on this battle over the last
40 years to really fight this because it
really does the West has enough of the
voice and the Constitution and these
types of things that are based on you
know free speech and and enough about
both the powers of of getting a rifle
trial and all these other kinds of
things that that maybe make it more
possible for with freedoms to achieve
what you were just describing as
karmically destined to achieve yeah well
look what we fund that's why they hated
us so much was because we fund
Greenpeace all the alternative movements
you know we're liberal or open though
you know all doctrines all face all
sexualities it's like we were very
because we're outlaws you know so it was
like there's a little judgment and you
know I mean you've heard about
University of Mississippi all Studies
things are down there okay well when
Israel and the rest of the world started
actually testing cannabis it only took
them about 20 years for them to really
realize the medicinal aspects discover
all that and really movement okay well
the University of Mississippi started
working on that 10 or 15 years before
the Israelis they knew all of this they
knew every bit of this and I've said I
don't care because I don't care about
putting people in prison and going back
to that it's just too late for that
but my mom died I have all kinds of
family members have died of cancer and
different things that could have been
healed with cannabis and they kept that
from us knowing at some point they knew
the medicinal benefits of it and that
was a crime against humanity because at
that point they were withholding
something that was a proven thing to
them to heal people of epilepsy of
cancer different you know illnesses so
they probably knew that 10 15 years
before the Israelis and what they did
was they decided to really suppress it
because they didn't want us to thrive we
were talking about earlier that thriving
thing they also realized okay look at
the building materials so you can make
out of hemp look at the creek look at
the clothing look at everything it was a
renewable resource yeah but it doesn't
work with there
you know always recycling and making you
buy more and throwing it away we're not
a it used to be I grew up a Sears you
want to give Sears craftsman tool and it
lasts for 20 years you get a Kenmore
anything we don't live we're a Kmart
Walmart everything breaks within one
year and it all just gets replaced and
recycled just like we are
we're just fed toxic food toxic air
toxic drugs and then we're just spit out
suck dry and then we're just regenerated
and that's what they created as a world
for us and it wasn't thriving and
cannabis was a major part of that
because they realized we'd really thrive
and well they liked cannabis out and
started healing all these people and
started making them not drink or do hard
drugs and then we could start using all
these reusable products what was that
going to mean for them interesting
that's what it was whoa okay so let's
some there's obviously a lot of other
stuff that we can talk about but I think
what you're talking about right now is
important to keep our let's keep our
attention on that so okay so there's a
lot of of economic and political and
social forces that push for a very
specific way that humanity functions
where it can be squeezed out a human
like an orange into the machinery for
the profits to funnel up for only a
specific amount of people and then just
have them die and then just cycle into
the next person filling that role and
the machinery squeeze it out again
versus the which feeds into that
consumptive conspicuous cycle of
materialism like that that again
benefits where does the money funnel
into versus a method that is geared
towards a holistic sustainable longer
term like you were saying getting
something about last 20 years instead of
one things like that so let's talk about
your knowledge about that that sounds
like it's very fascinating
to dive deeper into that well we do
regenerative farming at the air mo Cup
because we have to teach people how to
regenerate their farms we strip the
topsoil off everything across this
country if you know you talk about
integrity I thought our panel was today
okay
cannabis people were integrity base
because it was handshakes that was word
of mouth that was trust used to be
ethically Sears was it was about based
on every company in America was built a
Ford everybody had great great products
okay when they decided it's a bigger
piece of the onion but when they decided
peeling million back to not have a
strive and it was like okay we're gonna
have to take away the sustainability of
this place specifically America because
what they did here was when they took us
out of the gold standard off the gold
standard onto the oil standard in 1972
whatever they did we went from zero debt
to 30 trillion in 40 years or whatever
up 50 years almost and they basically
bankrupted this country which was taken
probably two or three hundred years to
do for us to have become Rome would have
taken two or three hundred years they
brought us to almost third world country
status within 40 or 50 because they
needed to bring us to their knees bring
us to our knees so they could basically
dominate us because we were not gonna be
very controlling like the rest of the
world so they got together and said okay
you make toxic food you make toxic drugs
you ruin the water systems you make the
laws that destroy these people you know
you bring in all the drugs from Asia and
stuff while the pharmaceuticals kill
them off and we're just gonna basically
wipe these people out and dummy them
down to where they're basically not very
intelligent they're very slow of
thinking they're sick all the time and
we can control them you know almost like
the matrix will just feed off of them
and spit them out and so that's what
they've done and look at those today
well you can call the New World Order
deep state you can call them whatever
name you want to call them you know I
don't care what the name is but
basically the people that run this world
that you know if you go back what did
they do in the 30s you know the Bush
family came in they created the Federal
Reserve and the IRS that was to start
the taxation of us they didn't even put
taxation above any number because they
never thought they taxes more than 2% 2%
the average person's tax 30 to 40 now
they were thinking the 2% would be so
radical they didn't have to put a lid on
it okay but that's because they were
going to create the Federal Reserve
take our money supply away from us and
bring us to our knees I don't think at
that point they were thinking about
killing us all
I don't think they were really I think
they were just gonna dominate us you
know financially then as they got going
and they started realizing a lot of
stuff that was happening I was told then
read of paper that they did a study
scientific study in the late 50s
projecting would it be like at 2010 and
they said I'd be overpopulated hard to
control people hard to teach them to not
procreate and do all these things and
that they had two choices either to
really do a massive educational drive
and try to stop all this or to basically
figure how to get rid of 90% of the
people and that's what they did they
created a program to basically rid this
world in about 90% of the people and
what is that program what are those well
you tell the colors of it no pillars of
it hey basically the vaccines that they
do they toxify us all the
pharmaceuticals all the stuff that they
give us his children to basically weaken
us and weaken our immune systems all the
food that basically just poisons us down
to the water the fluoride I mean I can
go 40 if chemtrails I can just go right
through everything you know the average
person wears a cotton shirts it's that's
a grown or in organically you can test
the chemicals coming onto your body
until you wash it four times okay they
know that so everybody walking around
that it gets a new thing from Kmart and
four washes they're just soaking toxins
into their body every way you could
think of they did and they were masters
at it and they did it so subtly that we
didn't see it you know it's kind of like
the Frog and the pot didn't realize it
the average person in 1970 today in
working in a fast-food place in the
making 37 dollars an hour so you guys
are young in 1970 a man working as an
electrician could have a house three
kids a wife no debt have the boat and
have a property in the mountains okay
that's gone there's none of that now you
got two people working they can't have
half that okay they just took it out
from under us okay it's it's a masterful
job when you watch what they did and you
see it it's like actually for me it's
like being in the matrix I mean I look
around for us to the young ones are
starting to pick it up too yeah well you
realize this is all fake I mean it's
like I didn't vote for Trump or Trump or
Clinton they're all phony
but you know it's there it's all part of
the whole thing it's just what they did
to build this to dupe us you know and
that's what they did they did a
masterful job just a master picture so
so would it be fair to say that there
was some sort of conscious ascension
that was happening in the United States
and that there needed to be a control
mechanism that was implemented in order
to make it so that the Ascension
wouldn't cause a greater awakening and
rather to be suppressed in ways and then
there was the distribution of the
suppression across so many ways that are
seemingly invisible but yet at the same
time people argue oh my god I have the
look at these computers they're so
incredible or I have the fastest way of
communicating with people now around the
world or I can now get this this
incredible of the process of mapping my
body so that I can get rid of a
pathology now and so so there are all
these arguments that that we have so
much better you know standards or
qualities of a love life but it's also a
big question of who is in control and
what is in control is it necessarily
just the human or is there something
controlling the human as life feeds on
life as above so below
yeah well that's a fascinating place to
go because they saw the 60s come in and
they were going to stop that it's tracks
they weren't gonna let that happen
that's why they devised how to get that
out of there and bring cocaine in their
laboratories figure out what crack was
we're going to make super cocaine and
they did that because they had to derail
that consciousness this was blossoming
and the interesting thing was is they
they cut the plant back to the root
but anybody knows with most things that
root will still grow and get stronger
and then have more to push out and so
what they did was they killed it all the
way back but now look at it forty years
later look at the psychedelic research
that's coming in and coming back look at
what cannabis has done no matter what
they did it backfired on them and just
blew up in their face and so it really I
think they almost pulled it off I think
they came very close to pulling it off
but it didn't work and now we're
basically faced with these people that
rule the world that realize it's not
working they're not going to be able to
finish us off they're not going to
control this the way they went
do you think too soon we have artificial
intelligence robotics that are say yeah
we do 5g technology there's a lot of
things that are coming that we are
neural prosthetics there's lots of
interesting things coming that people
that's the next place are great they're
going to absolutely benefit us in every
way possible
which has a lot of upside potential but
it also has the other potential of
wiping out those 90 percent that you
were mentioning a little bit of earlier
yeah they're using 5g that they're gonna
toxify us more all the cell phones ruin
your brains I mean they they this stuff
I mean would you rather be in 1970 and
have a wife and two kids and be able to
go to the lake every weekend and have no
debt and have no stress see with your
kids every night or would you rather
have all these toys and all these phony
stuff and be debt ridden and be driven
crazy and hate your wife and be divorced
and living in apartment and people can
pick what they wanted that was a better
life we didn't get a better life that
was a better life a simple life was much
better wholesome people weren't sick and
they were doing a great job now ai is
gonna be the next thing Elon Musk and
everybody knows that AI they're going to
get smart enough to where they can do a
lot of stuff and I would say once we rid
the planet of this dominating conscious
personality that's trying to take it all
away from us then we have the chance for
the meek shall inherit the earth I'm
being the next challenge behind that I
think would be AI but this potentially
democratize the benefits of the planet
to more people to have the creative
flourishing the conscious ascension
happen around the world rather than just
concentrated into the
saying people kept saying that about the
Internet as well the Internet's gonna do
that as well the maple this conscious
ascension so a lot of it blockchain
technology all these things keep coming
cannabis keeps you know all these things
keep coming and the idea is that can you
make it so that the fruits are shared
widely and enable the this future utopic
more utopic world that we want to all
live in or is it going to again cause
economic bifurcations and wealth and all
these other types of yeah i think that
it would have done all of that twenty or
thirty years ago i don't think that's
gonna happen all the stuff i've seen
with conspiracy circles and what i have
seen happening right now is that's about
to end we're gonna have a very very
interesting year ahead and why i think
you're gonna see free energy systems
coming out and being oust over the next
couple years oh it's in the pendulum
swings into free and into freeing and to
them backing up and all of a sudden okay
well i guess we'll just there's twenty
eight patented free energy systems we're
going to let that go now and we're gonna
have to let the ability to produce food
much more efficiently so that we can
actually have people eat right and you
know it's going to come down i think a
lot of its gonna do is space I think
really say what you want about Trump but
if you look at a couple things he formed
the space force about a year ago people
were laughing at him and they're they're
mocking him and stuff so then about no
it's no it's no stupid move it's well no
months later then he formed the Space
Command and they said what's the many
put all the military under the Space
Command and he's done this in ways where
now all the villagers under the Space
Command okay and what does the Space
Command well that's he says it to the
public that's cuz we're doing so much in
outer space and they're thinking oh
we're launching some satellites and he's
like no no we're like way beyond that I
mean my my ultimate thing since I'm a
little kid like you said it the first
ones that go to the next rocks are the
ones that get to pick the rules that
govern those rocks well I think it's
even yeah it's way bigger than that is
where it goes for it because I was I was
studying you opposed since I was a kid
I've been interacting with you up
area 101 has a billboard with the UFO
landing in the forest because of where
I've been I've got many many reactions
with UFOs that many people see them with
me I've been dealing with them since I
was a kid it's myself a little kid I
want to be the intermediary between our
space family and humankind I started
studying that when I was really young
I've learned a lot over the last few
years a lot of people coming forward and
I really learned what the real story
which is it's just so so deep and so
strong that people just are gonna
they're gonna really be in for a shock
of what when they really find out what
has happened in our world for the last
year 90 years when the real sodium does
it feel like it's this light and dark
that are pressing oh it's coming right
up against against and then and there's
an ascension that's happening we that's
what that's what's happening with them
both with them both basically that's
what you're I don't know if you're
familiar with the law of one one of the
books out there if you get into raw
which I had a hard time I wasn't even
really into that for a long time but if
you look at you know it's ying and yang
whatever else I mean there's fourth
dimensional evil and there's fourth
dimensional goodness too because it all
goes up together but you know basically
when the Germans were they were working
was like could you go back and you can
look at it the real society Maria left
read her name but she was a famous
psychic medium and she was channeling
some dramatist who were teaching her how
to build spacecraft or build him to move
through space and the Nazis heard about
the Germans heard about it and came
researched it all and realized that it
actually was very valid and started
working with that energy and actually
built spacecrafts that were working and
functioning at the other World War two
if you look at if you go back and look
in history they talked about unleashing
the the powerful most powerful weapon in
the world that would stop us but the
inside Nazis decided that they weren't
gonna sacrifice they would rather
sacrifice World War two and continue on
with what they're doing so they moved it
all the Antarctica and if you go
research you'll see my age people always
wondering why were all these Germans
down in Argentina and Chile in South
America seems like they all went down
there they were capturing or whatever
else that's because it was a jumpring
spot to our
America where they could work back and
forth and do their ships and then you go
back I he remember the famous photo with
the UFOs over Washington the White House
you ever seen that no you haven't
okay well go look up famous UFO siding
with the photo over the White House it
was on national television
these ships go over the White House and
it was because back then they weren't so
afraid of saying it this was before
Dwight and during with Dwight
Eisenhower's era Washington DC UFO
incident in 1952 alright what a White
House watch White House UFO flyover or
one of us and see what pops up now they
whitewashed a lot off the internet so a
lot of stuff you got to go find through
other researchers I have pictures of it
I can send you a book of the whole thing
it's a very famous thing now most people
thought that was UFO in the UFO
conspiracy circle we thought that was
UFOs right well it turns out that was
the German ships that came over and
checkmated us and said you can't stop us
we went through all of your your radar
all your military stuff there's nothing
you can do
and then he negotiated a deal with
Dwight Eisenhower and that's what Dwight
Eisenhower made that famous speech about
be aware of the industrial military
complex because we made a deal with
those people to going partnership and
that's when he told John F Kennedy and
that's when they killed Kennedy for him
trying to stop and that was the end of
our democracy as we know it okay and so
what we did wasn't always vain me to
deal with Dwight Eisenhower basically
Dwight Eisenhower and our military he
himself was part of it and got together
with this this German group and
basically made a deal to surrender in a
sense but in doing that wouldn't have to
give up any sovereignty and they would
share technology because what happens
was the Germans are down there in
arctica they have the space technology
they have it all how they going to build
it where they getting the materials they
need the energy of our manufacturing
plants of everything we have to build it
to get into space and so after they
checkmated us Dwight Eisenhower got in
with all the original North level
Lockheed Boeing all those people which
became the beginnings of the outer space
program the black ops that's what all in
black well what happened went white was
he was cut out that's when they formed
Aryan Aryan 51
well he wasn't allowed to go in there
after two years they decided that it was
going to be better since presidents were
gonna change every four years to not
keep them in the loop for their own good
and for the security of the nation's
good so basically they of some of this
begins at the CIA
Allen doles if you go back he was the
main dude in there and they leave doles
Allen doles do you lle yes he was a lot
of guys around majestic 12
they were the head of the CIA these were
all the beginnings of that and they came
in and moved it out
so they wouldn't let Dwight in and
that's what he realized he'd lost
control of it yeah and he wasn't in
charge anymore and that's what he made
that famous speech before he retired he
was like be aware of the
military-industrial complex because
that's all I can tell you is we lost
control of our world and he told John F
Kennedy and then they killed Kennedy
over it because he tried to stop him it
wasn't a body the rest that [ __ ] is
because he came and threatened them all
and then they basically so what they're
saying is if you go back and study with
Tompkins William Tompkins when Tompkins
was a genius kid he went and his dad
took him to the Naval Yard in San Diego
and from memory he designed and crafted
wooden ships of every one of the ships
with all the high-tech stuff they did
and he put a display for like a Macy's
thing and and sent downtown or something
and the military got so freaked out they
saw that they thought he was a spy or
something who could do this and they
found this 17 year old kid and they're
like oh my god so what they do they
jumped him into the military made him
the head of the spy program because it
was genius technology and I IQ so he
became the head of the Germans the spy
program for us and what he started
coming back with was these freaking
Germans are building these anti-gravity
ships and stuff and they're getting
ready to go down to Antarctica on all
this well another piece of the puzzle
see you guys I track all this Admiral
Byrd went down to Antarctica if you go
back and look at it and Admiral Byrd's
trip to Antarctica he went with it it
was going
a scientific expedition but it was with
the giant military fleet and he went
down to rib those Germans and get him
out of there but they kicked his ass
those UFOs came and blew up all of his
[ __ ] and he limped back into South
America and then they covered the whole
thing up and everybody remembers it you
can go look at that whole thing and
stuff and that's when then the Germans
flew over us and said we've had enough
of this and so it became this whole
thing well wouldn't Tompkins was part
I'd whole thing so they jumped him into
the space program he designed the first
command center when went to the moon and
then he was the head of NASA systems
until 1984 okay he retired he wrote a
book if you really want to see the best
copy the best version you should get
Michael Saleh say when we're going to
space where are you you know the last
piece let's say just for us and stuff
those that went Tompkins work through
Michael Salah and you can get Michael
solace book on him as a PhD and he had
interviews with him before he died he
swears that we launched eight
mile-and-a-half-long spacecraft through
the Navy in 1984 to combat the military
industrial Nazi Federation and the
basically it's been Star Wars out there
ever since 1984 going on and that those
people are dealing with 700 UFO beings
and trading stuff all over the universe
now and basically that we're going to be
in for an amazing awakening once we're
told all this and it's supposed to
happen within the next couple of years
it's all coming they're preparing us
right now for it so we're going to
basically this place could become a park
we could manufacture off a planet which
they're already doing their
manufacturing at all a planet anyway and
then we could just take back this world
beast be a big part so that's what
you're going to see
I'm so excited to dive into this with
you on another round on the show there's
obviously still so much to unpack we
like asking a couple quick questions on
the way out that we ask our guests do
you think we're in a simulation I've
heard lots of that simulation a
simulation of God's mind mm-hmm you know
I mean it's all God and God's playing
out every one of us I mean it's really
hard for me when I really get it because
I get it at times and like he'd always
just has a crisis I realize I'm not real
okay no it was surreal we're just
figments of God's imagination in the
course of miracles they talk about it as
God had a thought and then all this was
created and instantly went back to
himself and we're just playing out the
remnants like movie scenes there's none
of this even real
so that's simulation from that
standpoint it's probably true I don't
like to think about it like facts I like
my reality but you know but the other
side of it is I've studied enough God
who said that we're gonna be with her
forever we're all gonna have our
individual souls and stuff I used to be
afraid to play enlightenment cuz I've
come very close to stages of
enlightenment from in so many years I'm
more of a monk than I am a cannabis guy
yeah
I've been meditating twice a day for 40
years so I was really afraid I'm lose
that part that fear coming out but don't
go any higher because you know illusion
identity noise you know once you lose
your ego
you're still there and you get to travel
the Stars with all of our space family
and go everywhere you just you're really
more God's servant and you're connected
to God you don't have any fear so I
don't think we're in an AI simulation
and then what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world it's just
pure service it's serving people you're
talking about a physical thing or what I
mean to me it's serving people that's
what God wants us to do is serve people
and what was Christ what was Buddha and
also the most beautiful thing in the
world is unconditional love and service
compassion for all sentient beings you
know money pod Mia
yeah that's really what it is that's
what we're here for this is a big school
and when you get pure enough you get to
graduate until they get to you coming
back learning lessons I love it
thank you solution thanks for coming on
our show really appreciate you yeah
thank you thank you guys are very
special
you guys are ranked you people where you
can thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking check out more of the links in
the bio to Tim's work also check out
more of the links about a new West
Summit support the organizations the
entrepreneurs the leaders around the
world that you believe and support them
help them grow you can find our links in
the bio below as well and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thanks for tuning in and we'll see you
soon all right that's a wrap
Wow so different the cannabis with a
little different direction that's okay
Wow yeah so what I want to teach I'm
finishing three books
[Music]
you
[Music]